So there are lots more things we can do with
strings. The next one I am going to talk about, is
selecting sub-sequences from strings. So what we have seen so
far, we have used indexing, where we have a string,
where we have our square bracket. We have some expression
that produces one number, and we have our closed square
bracket, and that gives us a one-character string. And whatever
position the number refers to in the string here. The other
thing we can do with square brackets is select
a sub-sequence of the string. Instead of just having
one expression here, what we can have is an
expression. This is also something that should evaluate to a
number, followed by a colon, followed by another expression.
Both of these expressions are numbers. And this will
evaluate to a string, this is a subsequence of
a characters in, the input string. So I called the
string s, the value of this number will call
start, and the value of this number will call
stop. And what the result is, is a string
that's a subsequence of all the characters in s,
and the string that we had here. Starting from
position start, so the number to the left of
the colon, and ending with position stop, but not
including that character. So it's going to really include the characters
from position start, up through stop minus 1. So this construct allows us
to select from any string A subsequence of continuous characters in that string.
So, let's try an example in the Python interpreter.
I'm going to initialize the variable word to be the
string assume. And using the single index operator we
saw initially, we can select a character from word.
So, if I select word index 3. That will
give us the fourth character, zero, one, two, three,
which is u, and when we run that, we
see the result is u. With the new operation,
that's the same as selecting word 3:4,
that's going to select starting from position three, going
to just before position four. So that will end up being just the one letter u.
Just to make this clear, if I selected
3:3, there's no string there, that's just a
single empty string which prints out in a
way we can't see it. There's no characters
between 3 and character 3. We'll go back to
just selecting index 3. I could select from position 4
through position 6. That would give us a string which
is a subsequence of letters at position 4 and position
5. So when we run this now we see the
first one prints out to u. The second one prints
out me which is position 4 and position 5. The
last two characters in the word. I'll show you one
other thing we can do. Which is, leave one of
the sides of the colon empty. So it we did 4:
to the end, that will select from position 4 to the
end. We don't need to actually count the characters to know
where the end is. So that will produce the same thing
as we did before. We can also leave nothing in front
of the colon. That will select from the beginning. So if
we do :2, that will select from position 0 up to
position 2, giving us the first two letters of the word, as. And we could
leave both sides blank, selecting word, [:],
with nothing on either side, well, it starts from the beginning, goes to the
end. That's going to give us the whole word. There's
no good reason to ever want to do this, but
it's consistent with the syntax where we can leave
one side of the colon empty and that means
selecting from either the beginning or the end.